hello and welcome to a special segment
of GameSpot's play for all we are
talking duel universe so if you've ever
played no man's sky or elite dangerous
or any other to these spacefaring games
you might be familiar with what duel
universe is doing but what if you smash
that all together
so we're gonna talk about that with JC
byyee who's appellee developer onto a
universe how you doing man hey I'm good
thank you yeah so first there's a lot
going on I think that people think of
star citizen as well when they look at
this or Evon line but kind of give us a
brief overview of all the things that
you're doing with dual universe yeah
well I'm gonna be you know maybe a bit
provocative we are none of the games you
mentioned there are bit of some of those
things in those games but really to
understand you were eating in 30 seconds
what universe is about I will give you
two things the first is that this game -
it's an MMORPG takes place in space a
new planet and so on but the key thing
is that one every player is playing in
the same world at the same time I'm
talking about potentially millions of
people sharing the same world at the
same time so there's only one server one
reality it never stops it's persistent
so it's about letting players construct
basically well we have an industry
gameplay we have economy we have
territory with PvP so we have all the
ingredients for to let you know players
build their own civilization that's
that's super ambitious super cool and it
has never been done before
there's no game that really covers that
or with that amplitude the second thing
about the universe is that in this world
everything is editable so you can edit
the planets to start with them you can
be whole to the ground you could take a
mountain out if you want if you have
time it's gonna be very long but it can
be done that's by the way how you
collect raw materials resources that you
can use in in crafting and so on but you
can then use the resources to build you
know
cities space ships open stations
anything you want and so that as I would
say maybe a bit of Minecraft every tache
to the you know the thing we're doing
even so the graphics are minecraft to be
clear but I mean it's based on what we
call voxel technic
it allows you to sculpt shapes the way
it's really beautiful the players have
already you know those who have access
to the Alpha I've already done
incredible things with you've been at
work with this for about four years I
believe I think that's yeah and yeah no
doubt ambitious and you've you're
entering a new phase for the game as
well I think this is the newest news as
it relates to a universe but you are now
going into a beta phase can you tell me
all the details about that yes totally
so this is a big news
we announced today so first there is the
date for the beta which is set on the
27th of August this year so we keep to
our schedule on our roadmap so as we
said during the summer of 2020 that's
happening that's going to be August 27
it's a big big milestone because we we
are going to reach you know with a
better a really playable game with all
the key ingredients for you know the
finger was talking about your
civilization and merging the other big
announcement is that now we we
officialize our business model was the
price and you know things that are very
concrete so we we aim for since the
beginning for subscription we can
discuss you know why why not would you
play it's related to the nature of the
game the fact that you cannot be reset
its persistent at all but what what is I
think fairly new is that we've decided
to go with a very low price point so
it's going to be $6.99 per month and
we're gonna sell packages of three six
months 12 months with no reduction in
the price so overall I mean you can play
for the game you can play the game for
one year for less than 17 or so that's
compared to other games it's very
reasonable but it allows us to us to
have a sustainable business model that
allows us to focus on the player and the
gameplay so you know we're not trying to
put you know the usual techniques that
you find in free-to-play so this is a
game all about players yeah it comes
with a subscription but you know $6.99
it's not that much and it believe it's
affordable yeah that that was a little
bit surprising because of the way the
trends you know like you said
free-to-play in micro transaction so
you're steering
away from microtransactions and slowly
relying on the subscription model no
we're gonna have some cosmetic items
that you can buy but it will be purely
cosmetic of course so I mean your skins
for you give it personality to shape or
your character that's kind of knob do
you think I mean you don't have to buy
any of those and we're not going to
twist the game the way that you really
feel you have to buy any of those that's
the key thing right well sure I mean if
people want to spend more money we're
gonna have you know ways for people to
do that but it's not gonna be the way
the game is designed right that's I
think the key difference I think the one
thing for me that I'm most interested in
is how you're facilitating in-game
markets in the in-game economy that's
actually a very important point you're
right because this is like the nervous
central system of the of the game the
markets in the food game design that we
will get there at some point people can
create markets right now they're created
by us so you get a lot of markets over
around on the planets and if you go in
those markets you can put by other set
others and you can actually trade it's a
real market I'm not going to go into
details but I mean think of Wall Street
or I don't know it can market I mean the
way it works and so you can go in those
markets you don't need to understand how
it works and you can just go and instant
buy something it would get you the best
price for what you want but this is a
very important feature of the game it
allows in fact specialization so as a
player you're not expected to do all the
game planes while you can if you want
but the point is that you might
specialize in one thing let's say you
want to be pirates you're gonna be
flying ships and you know destroying
other people shape so you get that stuff
that's how you make your money right but
you don't know how to build shape so
maybe you like to customize them them a
little bit but you don't build ships you
go on the market and you buy those shoes
so that's the spirit and the game is
super long so it's it's very difficult
for someone to actually from collecting
materials that are actually in the
ground you can we access them like that
there's a few of them on the surface you
know that is entry-level materials of
the easy stuff I mean from getting there
to having a mothership with
when people is very hard to do all by
yourself it's like the world the real
world in the industry you don't build an
iPhone by yourself literally I mean even
if you want to build the phone I think
it's possible you can buy spare parts
and things but you're gonna buy six but
I'm not coming from the ground right
it's things that are already possible
you made by other people so the same
logic applies there is a full fledge
economy people specialize you buy
whether you don't care or when you don't
know how to do and you sell would you
would you do that or hear you making
business is taking a lot of people stuff
and it's your decision
are you free prices are set by the
equilibrium of supply and demand
right so we don't know the price of
stuff and they may have different prices
in different places in the world
depending on scarcity depending on you
if this planet has a lot of ayran ayran
problems going to be cheap on that
planet no but that that's all up to the
players to to decide or I would say to
emerge yeah that actually leads in some
one of my other questions is how much
player control do do the players have
when it comes to establishing their
communities because I know that one of
the mechanics you can do is establish
organizations establish nations so what
kind of rule sets are they gonna be
working with and also how do you
regulate that if you want to well it's a
very complex question that I'm gonna
give a very quick sketch to answer yeah
the equivalent of guilds or what we call
organizations it's a generalization of a
concept that can actually apply any two
nations for those who to corporations or
even group of pirates or friends that
would be groups in they're the same same
term it is an organization normalization
is composed of negates if you want those
guys they own the organization and they
have the rights to vote and they make
decisions and in particular the control
of the right management system that is
the system in the game that law allows
you you know to set for every given
asset that the organization owns and on
the other sides in an organization's you
have members they they don't own the
organization they can come and go and
they are usually put in certain roles
and that's the structure and if you
think about it if you look at a company
I mean you have shareholders those guys
are delegates and your employees those
guys are the members and we hope that
some really great things going to emerge
you can maybe invent a new way of new
kind of organization whatever and that's
really cool too I mean to observe
already and and we think it's also good
to play where is your position on kind
of handling moderation have you seen
places where you need to get involved or
has it generally been going the way as
you planned or have but like the players
been taking care of their own
communities have any major incident any
problem and I think it's because you
know the people paying in alpha they pay
a relatively high price they're going to
support the game they are big fans so I
don't think this is necessarily
representative of what's gonna happen in
the long run
so we answered all sorts of measures as
usual you know it's not just one silver
bullets to cover that there are ways for
you to report things that you that don't
follow the you know the user License
Agreement
you have waged in the game in the game
mechanics to set properties so like
territories why not let people dig in
the ground if you don't give them right
that's very important to say I mean it's
not like a free formal PvP game right
there's a large area of the world about
non PvP so in those areas you can not
even you break that door by actually
shooting at it
so there are particularly impossible to
do to open if you don't have it right
now if you go in the PvP area it's a
different story you might be attacked so
you might take your territory and and
clean your stuff I mean you have to
defend that it's another story it's very
interesting but players have a choice
what purpose does PvP serve in the world
of due to a universe like is it hinge on
agreements of war are there what's at
stake when you do engage in PvP
what's at stake is usually the ships and
the properties that are potentially
under attack but also indirectly also
the territories so this is not
I'm talking about right now in territory
warfare it's the fault of the PDP that
will take on the surface of planets but
anyway the the reason why you want to go
in creepy is first maybe you're a pea
right so you only take that stuff you
want you wanna you wanna steal that that
ship from somebody that's one reason
because you want to make money the thing
is we want to make it so you know
defense is favored against offense that
is that sure you can go and attack
someone but it's gonna cost you it's
something you need to plan and think and
if you act rationally it's maybe not the
most efficient way to solve you issues
we know that somewhere else we want to
pay no agents of chaos so that's fun but
I mean they might actually have a hard
time because it's not like you can just
say oh I don't know what to do tonight
I'm new to our universe I'm gonna go
with three friends on Saturday evening
and we're gonna blow the most awful
organization and fire man there's
there's so much to unpack but I do have
at least one more full question here it
is might be a broad one but what exactly
is it that players are striving for in
dual universe okay thank you answer you
in a funny way I'm gonna say what do
people ask what are people striving for
in real life it's up to you
you do what you want this this world
will need to feel real and so yeah you
may be you want to be super rich maybe
you want to have a lot of power maybe
you want to be feared by everyone maybe
you just want to be solo in in one place
and just build beautiful stuff that's
completely fun and it's up to you to
find your panels in the game and that's
the beauty of it I think so I'm not
going to answer that question and I can
tell you you know what you can do in the
game we've put a lot of things in it so
I think you can do a lot of things
already but it's up to you I think to
figure out you your path and that's the
beauty of it sweet alright well is there
anything else you want to touch on
before I let you go right I think we
forgot to talk about something important
is the the platform's where you can
actually
so we decided that for now we're not
gonna be on steam or a pistol we're
gonna be on our website doesn't mean
we're never gonna be there but it's
something we need more time with and
folks who are interested in getting into
beta they would just go to the website
pick a subscription model download and
get into it that's right and once you
can create a game is free you can
download it as you said when you want to
log in you need to have an active
subscription that's it so all right
sweet
JC byyee thank you so much for taking
the time to talk about dual universe I'm
sure we'll talk again because I'm sure a
lot of new things are going to happen
when the beta hits so thank you for
taking the time for sure thank you for
having the night and all of you out
there thank you so much for watching us
that's duel universe again and you can
check that out very soon and we have so
much more coverage here on GameSpot for
play for also check out all of our
developer interviews all the gameplay
and all the news that we've been
covering we'll see you there
you